[Music]
straight ahead
on lawn crime daily carol baskin praises
a deputy's level thinking
for responding to a tiger on the loose
and his alleged owner denies it's his
this man had absolute nerves of steel
sean aka stixx larkin joins us to
discuss his new podcast
cocktails and gives us a preview of his
interview with a 91 year old police
officer
with no plans of retiring
most people know me prosecutors rest
their case in the trial of a former
deputy
accused of planting drugs on
unsuspecting motorists
plus the trial of three former officers
charged in the death of george floyd
gets delayed until next year and our
coverage continues in the motion hearing
in the ahmad armory case the evidence
the defense wants in
and kept out of trial you're hearing it
now from me
it's not about the credibility of a mod
artery law on crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer
co-host terry austin is on assignment
covering the trial of zachary wester
where the prosecution has rested
in the trial of a former deputy accused
of planting drugs on unsuspecting motors
terry explains zachary wester is facing
67 charges including racketeering
possession of a controlled substance
and false imprisonment the charges are
related to allegations of planting drugs
while he was out on patrol
and for one florida motorist it was a
traffic stop
that changed his life we wish you a
merry christmas we
wish you merry christmas this is former
jackson county florida
sheriff deputy zachary wester as he
searches the car
of james fears i mean i want to hum a
tune in case something ever goes in
front of the jury you know
wester reportedly stopped fears while
his wife was
driving on june 4th 2018 for a problem
with their license plate tag what we got
there my friend look at there
all right both yards can be detained at
this time okay
i can undertain you i just can't
unarrest you wester places
james and jade fears into handcuffs the
deputies
explain they found dope in their vehicle
have you ever seen anything like that in
your car
no sir had you put anything back behind
that front
um the front passenger seat no sir
fears admitted on the stand he was
convicted of four felonies
he knew both wester and fellow deputy
trevor lee
from prior encounters fears was arrested
for possession of
meth but weeks later prosecutors dropped
the charge
saying the case could not be proven
beyond a reasonable doubt
on cross-examination fears told the
defense that he didn't see
either deputy plant anything in his car
do you have a
civil suit pending in this action yes
sir okay
and you sued zachary wester
yes sir and trevor lee
no sir no sir zachary wester yes sir
anybody else sheriff's department
sheriff department on redirect
fears explain why he's suing wester
and the sheriff's department because i
sold every damn thing i had to keep my
roof over my head
um i sold everything i had that was
worth anything
you told the deputy on that video that
you were gonna lose your job over this
and that you felt it was wrong correct
yes sir you still feel that way
you don't feel like this was wrong yes
sir it is wrong
wester has pleaded not guilty and his
defense attorney says
he will take the stand when they present
their case
for law and crime daily i'm terry austin
thanks terry joining us today is trial
attorney jamie white
along with the host of the newest
podcast on the law and crime network
cocktails tulsa police lieutenant sean
larkin now jamie the defense is going to
recall one of the witnesses
and two officers and actually anticipate
wester to testify
what kind of defense could we be looking
at here
it's gonna be a circus brian uh you know
it's very unusual
it's very unusual that a defendant
testifies in his own defense
and here i can't think of anything that
mr wester can't say that is going to
assist him
you know they found an extraordinary
amount of paraphernalia in the back of
his police car that could have only been
used
to assist and these unbelievable crimes
um so you know i i suspect there
it's a hail mary to find some sympathy
in the jury they only need one or two
people
to find that you know he's a nice guy
and
maybe a perverted point of view was
doing his job and therefore
doesn't deserve to go to prison but um
it's a very bad
choice in my opinion i'm part of the
defense counsel now
sean i'm seeing a lot of the prosecution
using uh
i think i think the best way to say is
juxtaposing wester
who they identify as a bad cop with good
cops like yourself
and trying to really drive home the
emotional impact of saying like this is
the one we have to go after do you think
that's a smart
tactic by the prosecution of showing
this is the bad apple to try to remove
from the tree that is
uh law enforcement uh sure it is because
i think the overwhelming
uh you know number of people in the
public they know police overall
are good hard-working guys that just
want to keep these communities safe
and i can tell you there's nobody that
wants a dirty cop gone more than the
good cops that are out there
and so by portraying you know showing
this guy is the bad apple
hey this other unit investigated them or
this group investity and
investigated them they themselves want
to get him out of here i think it's a
great tactic
yeah i think it's working out very well
we're looking at a lot of our chatters
on the
on youtube at law and crime commenting
on just that
and sean thanks for joining us because
you brought a sneak peek from one of
your upcoming podcasts
and this story really moves me let's
take a listen
to this interview with a 91 year old
police officer in arkansas
and you can tell us more on the other
side
well as long as you've been on the job i
assume you get a lot of respect don't
you sir
yes sir if you pull somebody over they
get out of the car and come back and
grab the ticket and then get back in the
car and drive off don't they
most people know me when i stop them
it's a bug shot
you know i know everybody
from maybe
five years old up
i helped a lot of people
sean that was a great interview and i
actually saw one of your
episodes really interesting i'm a little
jealous because i see in the background
there
that you actually get to share a drink
with some of your guests you got to tell
me how you got dan to agree to that
but tell us more about this officer
who's not planning on retiring anytime
soon
yeah so buckshot he is actually uh as of
yesterday
92 years old so we did the podcast
yesterday with him we kind of got to
have a
a celebratory drink uh he himself does
not drink but we had one in his honor
um but yeah he's been in law enforcement
this is his 57th year now
he did 46 years with the sheriff's
department he retired and was gone for
about five months and he just missed it
that much
that he then got hired by the local
police department and he is on his 11th
year there now
and just as he was talking about he
pretty much knows everybody
in that community um you know from from
five-year-olds on up to full-grown
adults and he's kind of a celebrity
in that area because he's been there so
long absolutely now
sean you may be retiring before officer
smith
but you still have plans to serve your
community tell us a little bit about
your plans after retirement
yes sir yeah i'm actually proud to say
tomorrow is my last day on the job here
in tulsa about a 25-year career here
kind of scared but i'm looking forward
to some of the new stuff going forward
just as we talked about the podcast is
something i'm really excited about you
know the name is cocktails i kind of
unofficially call it cocktails and
cocktails
and my co-host who you saw there is
howard doss he's a nice eu
nurse the two of us are big bourbon
collectors
and so the idea behind each show is
going to be a casual conversation about
a serious profession
the two of us are going to sit down and
talk with police officers informants
convicted felons
pretty much anybody that's touched the
law enforcement world through the years
and just try to talk to them about their
story but done in this casual
conversation
while we're having a drink i've got a
book coming out next month that i've
also partnered with dan
abrams on really excited about that
called breaking blue
and i'm actually going to volunteer and
work with a cold case unit here in tulsa
oklahoma
that kind of looks into some of the
older unsolved homicide cases
well sean if you ever need a public
defender wood for reserve is my drink
thank you very much for joining us i've
got you buddy
all right still ahead on law and crime
daily the perfect expert weighs in on
the case
of the missing tiger in texas but first
the shocking allegations defense
attorneys for the three former police
officers charged in the death of george
floyd are making
against the government why are their
trials now delayed next
[Music]
welcome back major news out of
minneapolis where the trial of three
officers charged in george floyd's death
is delayed until march 2022 law of
crimes and janet levy is here with that
arguments that took place about a leak
and a claim that the medical examiner
was cohorsed
yeah brian a lot going on in judge
cahill's courtroom for this hearing
he has actually delayed that trial he
said in part because of pre-trial
publicity
and the fact that all three of the
officers and derek chovin are facing
federal civil rights charges
former minneapolis police officers
thomas lane alex king and tu tau will
not go on trial in the death of george
floyd
until the federal civil rights case has
been resolved
defense attorney joe tamborino practices
in minneapolis
the feds have to prove specific intent
not only did they intend to do such and
such acts but they did it with the
specific intent
to deprive mr floyd of a specific
constitutional right
life liberty due process i think it's
all a heavy lift
a new controversy has erupted over this
new york times story published in
february
law enforcement officials were quoted as
saying derek chovin planned last summer
to plead guilty to third degree murder
in floyd's death
but attorney general bill barr stopped
the deal from going forward
former federal prosecutor gene rossi
expects a tense hearing over the leak
in august there are very strict
customs and practices with respect to
what you can say about a potential
guilty plea
or a trial minnesota assistant attorney
general matthew frank said in court that
it appears u.s department of justice
officials leaked the information
judge cahill agreed meanwhile the
attorneys for the three officers have
filed a motion
claiming prosecutors coerced dr andrew
baker
the medical examiner who conducted
george floyd's autopsy
they want the charges dismissed because
of it i think it's sort of a misguided
motion
tamborino says the claim will not result
in the charges being dismissed
the defense claims forensic pathologist
dr roger mitchell who volunteered to
testify for the state
pressured and threatened baker to
include net compression
in his cause of death ruling after baker
told him he saw no
signs of asphyxiation in floyd's body
the minnesota attorney general's office
called the claims bizarre
false and wrong in a letter to the court
if
it did occur that he was lobbying him
mitchell was trying to work the umpire
to get him to change
a call from a ball to a strike or safe
to an out
if it appears he was trying to do that
that
looks horrible
now the defense attorneys are also
asking for sanctions to be levied by the
court against the prosecutors involved
in this case
now i contacted dr roger mitchell he is
a professor
at howard university he told me in two
emails that he would not be
participating in any stories about this
topic
and i also contacted the spokesperson
for dr baker the medical examiner
in hennepin county and she told me that
they will not be commenting on any
pending litigation
brian thanks ange let's bring in trial
attorney jamie white
jamie dr baker being pressured in how he
made that medical exam report
i've never heard a kind of allegation
like that i would say it's bizarre as
well but if
true how does that play out for the
three officers and even chauvin
well i think it's subject to
interpretation brian um
you know at the end of the day there's
nothing extremely unusual
about prosecutors working with their
detectives their officers their
experts and challenging their
conclusions
this happens you know they're the
prosecutors are working from a multitude
of sources
and each individual source um
can arguably contribute to the next and
so in this case the idea that mitchell
and the prosecutors took some exceptions
with the um
with the finding of the forensic
examiner i
i suspect what they're going to argue is
that his findings were inconsistent
with what all of the evidence suggested
in particular the videotape where
it was clear that he was suffering um
from the knee on the neck so i
understand why they're making the
argument you know they have to do
something i suppose
but i think the likelihood of it having
any significant impact i think is
relatively far-fetched i agree with the
prosecutor's response
now and jeanette cahill was kind of on
the fence about subpoenaing
the reporter who made that article
because of first amendment issues can
you talk more about that
yeah well obviously judge cahill was
furious
that that information came out right
before trial about a potential plea deal
with derek chauvin
and you know it really endangers his
right to a fair trial
now bringing in witnesses and having
them testify or fill out
affidavits people who work in law
enforcement who may have been part of
this to see whether or not
they were part of the leak that's one
thing but putting a reporter
on the stand and grilling a reporter
about who their source
is is pretty un-american if you think
about it there's
we're part of the fourth estate you know
journalists we're supposed to be holding
the government accountable and we're the
watchdog for the people so
putting a reporter on the stand and
forcing them to reveal a source
i can see why judge cahill would have
some heartburn over that
it is a first amendment issue and it's
really not the reporter's fault
it's the person who leaked the
information exactly let's see how that
plays out
coming up on law and crime daily should
a mont arbory's mental health records be
allowed in
at the upcoming trial of three
defendants plus
out on the prowl police in houston
continue to look for a missing tiger
carol baskin's reaction to how an
off-duty deputy handled the big cat
you don't want to miss
[Music]
we're back a man accused of evading
police after a tiger got loose
from his house has posted bail angela
labia is back
with some thoughts for some thoughts
from a tiger expert
i think you'll recognize yeah i think
our viewers are definitely going to
recognize her brian carol baskin she
owns the big cat rescue in florida she's
also one of the stars of that
hit netflix series tiger king now baskin
told me that she was actually very
impressed by that off-duty sheriff's
deputy
who pointed his gun at the tiger earlier
this week in houston
but didn't shoot that tiger wandered
away from a home
in a neighborhood and had been in a home
rented by a man named victor cuevas
cuevas claims self-defense in an
unrelated murder case
he was arrested on charges that he
evaded arrest for possessing that tiger
now the nine-month-old tiger is named
india and he remains missing
the only reason that the cat didn't kill
the guy with a gun or end up being
killed
trying to was because it was nine months
old it's still a baby
and that cat will be growing until it's
four or five years old that's when it
becomes sexually mature and becomes an
adult and in the wild would kill its own
parents
to take over their habitat so you know
that's you know anybody who thinks
they're going to raise that cat up and
it's going to love them like a parent
for its entire life is
doesn't know anything about tires
because that's not how they work
oh carol baskin she's actually offering
a five thousand dollar reward for the
safe return of india
and cuevas's attorney he says that he
actually doesn't own that tiger
he said it actually belongs to a man
named deandre
brian i never thought carol baskin would
be an expert on police use of force on a
tiger but here we are
what else did she say about finding this
missing tiger
well she's gla you know she wants it
found because she said there are places
that
will take care of this tiger and allow
it to live in the wild but certainly
you know a tiger should not be kept in a
home it's just not the proper place for
it
and it could harm somebody once it gains
sexual maturity as you heard
absolutely that's best to keep everyone
safe there when we come back
back into a georgia courtroom for the
second day of testimony
and a hearing for the mod arbory case
the evidence the defense is trying to
keep
out on trial next
welcome back day two of motions hearings
in the ahmad armory hearing
as the defense attorneys for the three
defendants are asking a judge to admit
aubrey's mental health records
into evidence father and son gregory and
travis mcmichael are charged with
murdering aubrey while he was out
jogging last february
a third man william rhodey brian is
charged with boxing aubry in
while filming the incident the
defendants claim aubrey was a burglar
running through their neighborhood and
say aubrey's mental health records show
his response was to get angry and
aggressive
abra is on probation at the time of his
death and prosecutors say those records
are privileged
they're claiming self-defense against a
man they did not know
a man who they saw running down the
street
we've got about a 10-minute incident
mr aubry says absolutely nothing during
that entire 10 minutes
so when they say i was acting reasonably
that has absolutely nothing to do
with mr aubry's mental health it is not
critical
to their defense it is okay to recognize
and celebrate who ahmad arbory was
in 2012 when he graduated high school
but it is reckless to disregard
the mental health illness that plagued
him
for eight years leading up to this
moment
in february of 22 february 23 2020.
the defense is also trying to keep
jailhouse calls made by the defendants
out of the trial
including one where gregory mcmichael
can be heard agreeing with his brother
that no good deed goes unpunished
i got my mask on everything i'm trying
to sleep but i can't if
i wake up every 15 to 20 minutes you
know
you know have you bothered me you've
heard dale saying uh no good deed good
punishment yeah well
yeah that's it that's the best example
right there
the state portrayed the meaning of that
to be the good deed is the killing of a
mod arbor
being punished for is what's happening
by being charged and
incarcerated which is not what
mr mcmichael meant he meant
patrolling his neighborhood and trying
to capture someone suspected of crimes
in the neighborhood
as the good deed that being punished for
it was then being charged with murdering
him
let's bring in jamie white one last time
so the fence is trying to keep some
information in and
and keep some of it out but let's speak
specifically
do you think there's even an argument to
show some relevance
to aubrey's background to bring it into
the case
no brian and i don't believe that that's
really their goal here
i believe the defense is purposely
arguably trying to
paint the public picture and the jury
pool with a dark side
of the victim in this matter you know
anybody that's attended law school and
has any relative
experience trying cases knows that the
mental health records of an individual
that's been murdered are not relevant
you know he could have been um had the
mind of a two-year-old
but it wouldn't have changed the facts
of the situation um
as they lay here today so i think
they're acting in bad faith and i
don't believe in any world that we live
in legal world we live in the judge is
going to allow these in
now i also know the judge is going to
rule later on that
as well as whether or not the jailhouse
statements will come in we'll make sure
to follow with that
jamie thank you for joining us and thank
you for joining us here at law and crime
network we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you